thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you
Orlando what up morning morning sit
let's do this I love you so much
good morning thanks dude so I want to I
want to get some things in this morning
I want to talk about a couple of core
things I want to talk about two very
opposite things one probably more
mindset just kind of what you know it's
funny when I think about motivation and
mindset they don't come natural to me
it's not what kind of gets me going
it it it really goes into a place more
of just strategy to me it's just
practical if you're actually optimistic
or if you're in the right place you're
able to do the actions needed to get the
results that you want so I want to talk
a little bit about strategy I think some
will take it into motivation and mindset
that's fine and I'm thrilled but it's
strategy aka let's just get actually I
can make this very quick we are just
completely in this incredible place of
unlimited options I just struggle with
people's inability to have perspective
on where they sit an opportunity in a 7
point 7 billion person world if you are
sitting in this arena this morning
you're ranked amongst the seven point
seven billion people in the world when
it comes to opportunity is [ __ ]
ridiculous
I have the privilege of being a well
member of a nonprofit called charity
water and I highly recommend you take a
look at it if you actually whatever you
come cleaned about in the last 48 hours
if you understood that there are
millions of people who don't have access
to fresh water who literally woke up
this morning and walked seven miles one
way and then back to create some level
of fresh [ __ ] water for their family
when that [ __ ] was literally accessible
to you in the sink in your bathroom you
[ __ ] complain you are [ __ ] out of
your mind I literally feel that so much
of what I'm able to accomplish or the
happiness I have and honestly [ __ ] a
focus group of one when I look at
thousands if not hundreds of thousands
of other people who are happy forget
about Benzes and shoes and homes and
planes the ROI of life is not money it's
being happy and when I look at the
people that I see that are happy
regardless of their income levels or
success or fame or notoriety or money so
much of that is completely predicated on
the fact that either their parenting or
circumstance help them have actual
perspective to what the hell is going on
here and so I will tell you this my
number one thing probably on the back of
the fact that my mom who had a difficult
life of losing her mom when she was five
and growing up in Soviet Russia and
plenty of things being poor when we came
to America the fact of that woman never
complained once probably had and I mean
once I lived an entire life where I
watched my mother live her life knowing
her circumstance and never complain once
of course that had a huge impact on my
inability or tolerance for complaining
when I know that the tens of thousands
of people in this room have the ability
to do whatever the hell they want
because oh by the way not only were you
blessed to be living in America not only
were you blessed with a million other
variable
but a lot of tweaked things that we talk
about and I'm so happy so many things
have popped up in culture where we talk
about you know unconscious bias or or
privilege and that's so good and I'm so
glad we're having those conversations
but the privilege that everybody in this
room has that your great-grandparents
didn't have your great-grandparents
didn't have your great-great-great
grandparents didn't have is regardless
of how much debt you have or
responsibilities or I have to feed my
kids or put clothes on backs or whatever
your thing is debt or responsibilities
or most likely you bought too much [ __ ]
you didn't need and now you have to work
to pay for that [ __ ] right because
so many people I love the people that
buy a home that has four extra rooms
that they never [ __ ] use and then
they have to keep a job that they
[ __ ] hate to pay for a house that has
four bedrooms that they never [ __ ]
use I know my guy facts but the great
privilege that all of us have is no
matter how tough it feels or what kind
of golden handcuffs you have or the
pressure that you feel the fact that
everybody here can eat [ __ ] from 8:00 in
the morning to 7:00 p.m. to pay their
dues and still come home and have this
thing this phone is more powerful
technology wise than the computers that
Ronald Reagan had to run the free world
this thing while you lay in bed from
7:00 p.m. to 2:00 in the morning
is your gateway to get out of the thing
that you complain about yet we'd rather
watch [ __ ] entire seasons of friends
again on Netflix
or go on Twitter and complain about some
dumb [ __ ] instead of the if you leave
with anything from my talk this morning
there's only one word that I like and
that's accountability how many people
here have a company how many people here
manage or have a company where they have
one or more employees raise your hand
raise it high amazing good news if you
ever complain about an employee it's
your [ __ ] fault you hired them you
could literally walk over and be like
hey Sarah you're fired
[ __ ] you could I am remarkably
stunned by the lack of accountability in
our society News Alert
Russia Russia didn't go in the booth
with you and pull the lever so stop
blaming Facebook [ __ ]
we uh here's one that you won't clap up
as much everybody [ __ ] on
Millennials you [ __ ] parented them
[ __ ] they're so entitled because you
entered them into a baseball league that
gave trophies to eighth place teams dick
face everything wrong at vaynermedia
anything that ever happens any piece of
content anything that ever happens in my
life 100 [ __ ] percent is my fault and
let me tell you what happens with
accountability you get real happy when
you feel that there's no other source
controlling your [ __ ] all of a sudden it
gets happier your ego and your
insecurities doesn't want to take the El
you don't want to admit that you [ __ ]
up because for some reason so many of
you are living your lives based on other
people's opinions and that is crippling
you so many of the actions in this room
if you're waking up this early to come
to this kind of event I know off the bat
in the beginning well every [ __ ]
person here has a percentage from 10% to
a hundred percent of living their lives
based on other people's opinions that to
me is what I want to get to zero if I
could actually get you to 1 to 2 percent
of living on other people's opinions you
would [ __ ] your [ __ ] pants on how
happy you would be you would you would
know there's an unbelievable liberating
feeling when you can look at your mom
and say mom listen I know you're
miserable but I'm done with this [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
and by the way I just hope everybody
nurses cuz I know plenty of you don't
know who I am and things that nature
it's not fun for me to say that I don't
want to disrespect your mom that brought
you into this world I get it
I just know that through the tens of
thousands of direct messages and emails
that I'm getting every single week that
so many people's struggles or not making
themselves happy is so predicated on
five to seven people in their lives that
they don't have the ability to have an
actual honest transparent conversation
about what that person's doing to them
and the standards or perfection or
judgment that they deploy on them is
affecting their behavior and I just
here's what I fear I feel like so many
of you do things especially with parents
because you don't want to upset them or
have confrontations in the short term
without realizing that that's gonna lead
to 50 years of regret and resentment and
I'd rather you have fights with your
parents for a couple of years and then
actually have a good relationship than
have a shitty one in perpetuity I know
literally do you know how many people
here are not executing and I'm gonna get
into social media strategy in a second
do you know many of you do not execute
on social media strategies properly
because you're worried when you post
something that six pants 44 says you're
ugly and then you [ __ ] and then you
don't do [ __ ] like literally there's
some anonymous comment of oh by the way
by the way if somebody let's just
Orlando can we do something here on the
record on the record on the record if
somebody takes a minute to leave a
comment that's negative on your account
they took the time out of their lives to
try to drag you down and [ __ ] on you
don't be sad for you
be sad for them
people like Garrity how do you do with
all that hate I deal with that hate
easily I look at the commenter like
you're full of [ __ ] you sucked at it and
I legitimately process in my head like
[ __ ] that person's life must suck [ __ ]
the thought that I would ever spend one
second to go to somebody's [ __ ]
Instagram account consume the content
and then say you suck is so [ __ ]
foreign to me my friends negativity can
lead at halftime kindness always wins
the game don't get it twisted so with
that all being said let me tell you why
I'm so passionate this morning I am
blown away that I know 99% of you
regardless of how deep you're in and I
by the way it's a hundred percent
including me we are not taking advantage
of how big this technology revolution is
this internet thing is way bigger than
we can comprehend because we're living
in it how many people here over 40 raise
your hands
amazing let's clap it up for the over-40
crowd how many people here under 30
let's clap it up for the youngsters all
right under 30 under 30 you're not gonna
believe this but us old [ __ ] we lived
most of our childhood without the
internet and it was [ __ ] crazy let me
tell you some stories kids let me tell
you how I tried to use to meet up with
my friends at the mall you would talk to
her in school and you'd be like yo Ricky
okay 4:30 at the fountain by [ __ ]
Macy's got it
now here's where [ __ ] got really [ __ ]
up and this is what I love when
everyone's like oh I hate all this
technology the old days were better was
it because I recall that when I would go
to the mall and can't wait to see Ricky
- go play [ __ ] arcade games at the
mall but there was traffic or his mom
was late and I'd be at the fountain at
4:30 and after about 15 minutes I'd have
to give up and leave and then at the
next day at school he'd be like we're
worried I was like by the fountain of
Macy's like [ __ ] I was by the fountain
by KB Toys kids under 30 we used to not
find each other we literally couldn't
find each other we have an incredible
ability in society to fear the current
and the future and put the past on a
pedestal we put the past on a pedestal
and we [ __ ] on the current in the future
that is legitimately why a bar enormous
percentage of people here will not be
able to succeed cuz you [ __ ] on this you
underestimate what's actually happening
let me tell you one thing that connects
every person here from the rafters up
there
what up Rick takes like an hour for it
to come up there you're like yo I'm like
talking about yo that's the one thing
that connects everyone here regardless
of you're winning you're losing company
employee entrepreneur the one thing from
coast-to-coast that connects every
person here is the one asset that we
should all be chasing is attention
before you achieve anything whatever the
hell you came here for when you go an
output to try to create your business
run for mayor raise money for a
non-profit no matter what you do no
matter what you try to accomplish when
you leave this conference the one thing
that you should be tape chasing is
people's attention before you can
accomplish selling a sneaker or a cookie
or a t-shirt or
surance or whatever you do you need
somebody's attention to tell them then
your message has to be on point enough
to commit them into doing what you'd
like attention my friends is the asset
nothing else is important to me besides
attention the reason I've always adapted
to new content and new platforms the
Internet itself email YouTube Google
AdWords Facebook Twitter podcasting all
of it the reason I've always done well
with that is my religion above anything
else is where is the attention today
and potentially tomorrow not what worked
yesterday so many people yes I know I'm
right
that's why I'm up here dick my friends I
love you Carl
listen listen attention is the asset
it's why everything changes when
attention changes the reason people the
reason are so much happening in society
globally not just America I love that
people don't understand people are so
under edged Americans suck [ __ ] at
knowing at what's going on in the world
we're so insular we are we you don't
understand what's happening in America
is happening all over the world
it's called nationalism what's happening
in America is happening in India what's
happening in America is happening in
many places in the world the reason this
is happening is because information is
changing the way we consume information
is changing Amazon growing and gonna
destroy Walmart has the same thing to do
with the reason why different points of
view and opinions happen there's so much
happening and it's amazing I actually
think it's amazing what's happening
because we're exposing so much so much
is now getting shed light on because the
media is changing in that macro trend
you need to figure out your micro
opportunity you need to understand for
example I don't care who you are in this
room if you're not buying Facebook and
Instagram ads for your ambition and I'm
saying the word ambition not business
because maybe you want to be the
president of the PTA and that will cost
you literally $180 on Facebook if you
know what you're doing you have to
understand that no matter what your
opinion is of technology it doesn't care
about your opinion and it's gonna
continue to do its thing so many of you
are not harnessing the power of this out
of ideological points of view and being
lazy to not put in the 50 hours of
homework to actually be good at it you
know many people here have run $1,000 on
Facebook ads it didn't work and are
sitting in this conference right now
with the opinion that Facebook Ads don't
work we have to put in the work we have
to put in the work this is a remarkable
time and let me tell you why I did not
make content that much from 2011 to 2014
on the internet for the people that had
been following me it was because there
was nothing remarkable for me at that
moment that made me compelled to
communicate at a high level
I sit here this morning and stand here
in front of you with regret on one of
the great accomplishes of my career I
walked into my dad's liquor store
business that was doing four million
dollars a year and very quickly grew it
to 30 40 50 million dollars in revenue
on the back of Google AdWords and email
marketing in the late 90s and early
2000s when nobody understood what that
was but I grew it to a 60 million dollar
business and the truth is my friends it
should have been 200 million I didn't
spend enough on Google AdWords when I
had the best hand when I knew Google was
special I spent 50 60 70 percent of my
money when it should have been 95 but I
kept doing direct mail and I kept doing
Wine Spectator comm and I did the
starlett how many people from Jersey in
here so I did the star [ __ ] ledger ad
and I did all that [ __ ] because I didn't
understand how historically special that
moment was on Google that Google was
this
unbelievable platform that we would
continue to use 20 years later to search
information and that the ads on it were
misunderstood at first for how powerful
they were thus they were underpriced
Amazon was the biggest spender on Google
AdWords the first five to six years
they used Google to become Amazon I know
that right this second as we sit here
this morning that Facebook ads and
Instagram ads are that same thing that I
lived through in the early 2000s I know
it because I've watched what it's doing
for me and for every business I'm
associated with whether it's a client or
whether it's a start-up or somebody that
emails me Oh 40 50 60 80 a hundred times
a week telling me that their business
sucked [ __ ] then they finally really
started listening started really
executing and good things miraculin how
many people here have run Facebook Ads
and it's done something good for their
business raise your hand actually stand
up stand up I want people to feel this
visual I want everybody who's standing
and sitting to understand why I'm doing
this not only have these people seen
success I promise you and take note of
who's standing and if you don't know
them ask them during intermission thank
you for standing you can sit now I will
tell you that if they tell you the truth
they will admit that they're not even
that great at Facebook I'm being serious
it is such underpriced attention that
even average execution even average
pictures and videos and words are
getting results because the attention is
so underpriced please if you leave this
conference with anything other than [ __ ]
I want to go all-in on accountability
because that's gonna get my mind right
and allow me to do [ __ ] other than that
you have to go all-in on Facebook and
Instagram the pricing is so remarkable
it is so under priced and all it will
take is 20 to 30 hours listen to me I'm
telling you I'm telling you and by the
way I want everybody to know why I'm
about to go into this little 3 minute
rant
this is not me being a good guy this is
very selfish d-roc where you at Haidee
Rock let's hear it for D Rock T Rock
can you move and come here because I'm
about to go into this ramp not because
I'm gonna be a great guy and want you to
like win I want to be selfish I'm about
to rant and tell you on the record that
98% of you Orlando 99% of you Orlando
are going to regret this day for the
rest of your life let me tell you why
because I'm about and right now I'm
setting up this moment I'm about to spew
something real heavy for four minutes
I'm gonna put pressure on you to do it
because for 80% of the 99% if you were
to do it you will see results yet
miraculously 98% of you will do nothing
that I'm about to say because you're
gonna be pumped as [ __ ] right now right
you're gonna be like yes I'm gonna
freeze where I'm gonna [ __ ] do it
Sally I'm [ __ ] doing it but next
Tuesday something Bad's gonna happen and
because your minds not right you're
gonna dwell and it's gonna create
inaction you're not gonna do it and so
I'm doing this selfishly because I'm
literally gonna take this video this
moment I'm gonna post it in seven years
to people that live in Orlando and a
hundred mile radius of it you're gonna
watch it in 2025 you're gonna see it and
be like [ __ ]
I hope so darling if you do me one favor
and you've got to go see Robert and Tony
and if I wish I was speaking last cuz I
would literally tell you [ __ ] faces to
stand up now and leave cuz nothing in
the next 10 minutes that I'm gonna say
is anywhere close to as valuable as what
I'm about to say go home and spend 30 to
50 hours which is zero time it's
absolutely no [ __ ] time in this
scheme of your life spend 30 to 50 hours
and learn how to be a practitioner in
running the ads aka targeting people
targeting real estate agents that live
in Kansas and making some reference the
the unlimited nature of the targeting
capabilities of Facebook and Instagram
is overwhelming
literally fans of the New York Jets
literally every brand could get my
business if they ran ads against fans of
the New York Jets and then the video and
picture was contextual to the New York
Jets they would get my business learn
how to target people read by the way
don't buy some [ __ ] $9,000 ebook no
it's free YouTube Facebook Google you'll
get free information there's tons of it
go run ten thirty eighty dollars at a
time against your picture and video and
written words on Facebook and Instagram
and sit back and marvel at how much the
results can happen but rest assure this
if you target somebody perfectly a
stay-at-home mom in Missouri that's into
fashion and you've got a fashion stay at
home mom product if you target it
perfectly please still know that the
picture and the video that you put out
is the variable if it will be successful
we target perfectly or extremely well
best-in-class
consistently right Vayner my team blah
blah but the variables of our success
horribly different based on how good the
picture and the video is my friends
right this minute late August 2018 in
your face in your face is one of the
great business attention opportunities
of our lives it will go away we will
wake up in a decade and Facebook and
Instagram won't be winning myspace is
not winning anymore
[ __ ] changes MTV is not winning anymore
right [ __ ] changes our attention moves
running ads on MTV in 1984 to teenager
great idea today [ __ ] terrible
running Facebook and Instagram ads today
and by the way I don't want to hear what
my customers aren't on it let me give
you a little news alert everybody 50 to
80 year olds on Facebook over indexing
and converting better than anybody else
Wow is right you know why first of all
all of them are on it your grandma's on
[ __ ] Facebook spewing her politics
either to the left or to the right the
other amazing things about really
[ __ ] old people they go really slow
which means they consume that [ __ ] the
[ __ ] teenagers like like [ __ ] grandma
Esther slowest [ __ ] if you can go very
basic on me and understand a couple of
truths truth number one attention is the
ultimate asset it's how everything good
ever happens
it's how everything bad ever happens its
attention you yes done nobody else be
rude or I'll punch you in the face
listen listen to me attention is the
number one asset you have to figure out
how to produce audio written words
pictures and videos for Facebook Twitter
Linkedin Instagram the reason to watch
my content is not for me to motivate you
on Instagram it's for you to watch what
I'm doing in getting people's attention
you should be consuming my content you
could listen some people takes 3 years
to figure out what I'm up to
right other people takes one day right
that's fine I don't care about that the
only reason I'd ever want people to
continue to follow my content is not for
my message it's super basic do the right
thing dick right that's my message cool
let's all move on the reason to watch my
content is to watch how I'm manifesting
and creating content on all these
platforms contextually to the platform
and then for you to replicate it for
whatever your mission is attention
number two just an enormous truth if you
let somebody else's opinion whether your
spouse your boss your mom your aunt your
best friend if you genuinely genuinely
are living your only life which oh by
the way by modern scientific terminology
is four hundred trillion to one if you
even could come
and how ridiculous it is that we are
even alive like literally your mom could
have gotten up and got another glass of
wine like literally like do you
understand how ludicrous it is that you
have a life
there's nothing mathematically in life
that can happen that is more ridiculous
than the fact that you got one you're
more likely to get struck by lightning
14 times than have a life yet
everybody's walking around here like we
[ __ ] deserve it like we're coming
back anybody people here or living life
like they're comin [ __ ] back listen I
don't want to get into religions and
[ __ ] but you're not coming back dick and
even if you are you're gonna be [ __ ]
like a rhino or a tree or a rock
imagine if that's act by the way I'm
gonna go so weird for a minute imagine
we actually did come back but it had to
be a physical object could you imagine
literally being a tree and sitting there
and be like [ __ ] I used to be a human if
you are living your only life based on
your older sisters point of view or guys
please please deeply understand how
truthful misery loves company is do you
know how much of your mom's advice is
predicated on her resentment and regret
on the advice her mom gave you and even
though she was so pissed at her she's
doing the same [ __ ] to you this is real
talk please do not live your life based
on your mom definitely not Sallie pants
44 in the Facebook comments I [ __ ]
hate Sally pants 44 and most of all
please stop buying dumb [ __ ] to look
good in front of people that you don't
like in the first place
and most of all and this is super
contextual to this event faking it to
you make it is very 1987 we now live in
a world where transparency has one speak
the truth do the right thing
kindness is cool truth is cool don't act
like you've made it talked about the
journey of trying to make it
authenticity is what rules in 2006 when
I stood up and I started talking and I
cursed it was fundamentally unacceptable
I missed out on 90% of my opportunities
people didn't like it but I couldn't
help it I'm from Jersey this is how I
talk and I know that there are people
still in this audience that don't love
and I respect that tremendously but let
me tell you something in 2018 wearing
jeans and a t-shirt and cursing at a
public event is a hell of a lot more
acceptable than it was 12 years ago I
stuck to my truth I worked every day
from 20 to 30 I've worked every day from
20 to 30 and never said a word I wasn't
a 20 year old life coach
I wasn't any of that I worked and
actually built a huge business built
businesses actually invested in Facebook
and Twitter in 2006 I actually did it
and then after 20 years of doing it then
I started talking about it a little bit
faking it to make it is the great flaw
of this generation please don't do it
please stop listening to anybody but
yourself please eliminate negativity
from your life because if you want to
really win it is absolutely by
reinforcing positivity
so get real quiet in here get real
selective about who you're spending time
with and most of all understand why I'm
pushing you into all this foofy-foofy
[ __ ] the reason I'm pushing you into all
of this kindness and gratitude and
compassion and all this good [ __ ] is
once you get there then you can put in
the 13-14 SiC then your mind do you
don't quiet it is up here you know quiet
it is right here for me I can't hear it
by the way pay very close attention to
what I'm bout to say not just the
negative the positive too when I post
something when somebody's like Gary you
walk on water
you are the best you're a genius quiet I
don't hear that either I'm on my mission
doing my thing and when it gets quiet
you get fast the reason I can work 17
hours a day is because I'm not spending
15 hours a day dwelling or looking back
guys nobody gives a [ __ ] that your
brother stole $1,000 from you six years
and we'll get over it dick forward
forward forward
mindset all of that leads to one thing
if you do not become a practitioner of
how to communicate on the social
networks of today you are 100%
irrelevant don't like it tough figure it
out execute it this is on the record I
don't want you to regret it in seven
years and I promise you in seven years
whether it's Facebook or Twitter or
schmitter and heyse book I will [ __ ]
find your attention and I will [ __ ] on
you for not doing something about it
today Thank You Orlando
you